So, the important thing about types is what we can do with objects of that type.
Depending on the type of an object, we can do something with it, but not others.
So, here's an example. The string type, or STR type as it's actually called, has
an operation find so if we have a string, we can do find on the string and that
gives us 2, the position of the 3 on the string. The list type does not have a
find operation. If we try to access the find attribute of a list object, it
doesn't have one, and we get an error. The error is giving us an AttributeError
that says, well, we had a list object, that's the object 1, 2, 3 that we created
here, and it has no attribute find, so Python doesn't know what to do when we
ask to find on a list. There are other operations like multiply that might work
on different types but have different meanings on different types. So, when we
do multiply where the inputs are integers, we get the results of multiplying
those 2 integers. When we do multiply when the first input is a string, we get
repetition of that string.